Paderborn muss sich nach einer 2-0-Führung noch Schalke mit 2 zu 3 geschlagen geben und nach diesem Wochenende haben wir eventuell unseren ersten Absteiger in die 3. Liga besiegelt. Wir sprechen über die 2. Bundesliga der Männer nach dem 31. Spieltag mit Anna Lautenbach und Thorsten Wiese und jetzt geht's los. Nun im Programm, der Rasenfunk.
Lagerflieg vorbei und der Ball ist im Tor! Und Augsburg ist oben!
Rossi zu Kurzabwehr, lang genug für Willi Landgraf! Wagner, Martin Wagner! Und das als Sonne. Markus Kurt aus dem Gewühl. Alexander Schur!
Der Blick auf andere Ligen.
Herzlich willkommen zur Ligatur, zur 2. Bundesliga, der Männer. Schön, dass ihr wieder eingeschaltet habt. Es ist Ende April, das heißt, wir sind auch alle langsam, aber sicher mit unseren Nerven am Ende dieser Liga. Mein Name ist Eva Lottabohle. Ich sage es, wie es ist, es war ein, also seit dem letzten Mal ist hier bei mir gemütstechnisch viel passiert. Ich glaube, bei meinen beiden Gästen auch. Falls ihr euch freut darüber, dass diese Sendung stattfindet und warum ihr denkt, okay, falls ihr die Bundesliga Sendung der Männer gehört habt, die gehört hat, das stand ein bisschen in der Schwebe. Nein, ich habe nicht so viel gefeiert am Wochenende. Ich sah einfach nur kurzfristig aus wie Rudolf und habe mich damit so einfach ein bisschen in der Jahreszeit vergriffen. Das ist zum Glück gut für alle Zuschauerinnen, wenn ihr so einen roten Punkt auf meiner Nase seht. Ich habe auch keine drei Flaschen Schnapps vor dieser Aufnahme getrunken, um irgendwie durchzukommen. Man weiß es nicht so ganz, woran es liegt und vielleicht ist das auch schon mal ein gutes Stichwort. Für so ein paar Punkte in dieser Folge, woran hat es gelegen. Aber nach der Folge der schlechten Laune bei den drei Mitgliedern der letzten Folge, darf ich heute zur Folge der guten Laune begrüßen und damit back-to-back auch Anna Lautenbach vom Gegengratepodcast hier begrüßen. Hallo, Anna.
Ja, vielleicht dazu kurz ergänzend. Ich habe ja Uwe Rösler anderthalb Jahre in Düsseldorf erleben dürfen als Trainer. Und natürlich gibt es so die Außendarstellung. Und ich glaube, wir haben vor ein paar Sendungen auch schon mal darüber gesprochen, inwiefern das sinnvoll ist oder nicht. Aber wenn man sich seinen Fußball anguckt, sehr pressingintensiv etc., aber tatsächlich wenig ballorientiert. Und ich glaube, das ist ein Problem, was man auch diese Saison bei Bochum sieht, dass sie sich mit dem Ball mitunter schwer tun. Das ist gerade nämlich schon gesagt. Spielaufbau wirkt manchmal etwas chaotisch und nicht so zielführend. Man sieht zumindest auch in der Ballbesitzstatistik Bochum ist das Team mit dem wenigsten Ballbesitz in der gesamten Liga. Das verwundert dann eigentlich, dass man in Heimspielen dann trotzdem so erfolgreich ist, weil man ja davon eigentlich ausgeht, dass man gerade in den Heimspielen da ein bisschen was machen können. Aber das ist eine Schwäche, die auch bei Uwe Rösler nach dem Abstieg in Düsseldorf in die 2. Liga ein bisschen zum Tragen kam. Denn tatsächlich haben wir beim Bundesliga-Abstieg häufig durchaus überzeugend gespielt. Natürlich aus dieser Rolle des Abstiegskandidaten mit viel Umschalten, Pressen etc. Aber in der 2. Liga hat das gar nicht mehr so gut funktioniert. Klar, Kader hatte auch einen großen Umbruch. Aber eben, da war eben das Problem. Jetzt bist du der Absteiger, bist vor Thuner Düsseldorf. Du musst mit dem Ball was zeigen, vor allem in deinen Heimspielen. Und das hat häufig nicht so funktioniert. Das ist eine Schwäche bei Uwe Rösler. Und ich glaube deshalb, das passt auch so ganz gut zu deinen Beobachtungen. Das wollte ich dazu noch sagen, bevor wir vielleicht so den Blick in die Zukunft richten. Und ich wollte einfach auch vielleicht euch fragen. Als ich über Bochum nachgedacht habe, weil ich ja wusste, dass wir über sie sprechen, habe ich mich gefragt, welche Spieler bei Bochum haben diese Saison eigentlich wirklich überzeugt. So, dann bin ich– als Düsseldorfer fällt es mir schwer, aber bin ich an Timo Horn, auf Timo Horn gestoßen im Tor, ja. In der Hinrunde überragend, jetzt immer noch gut. Und auf jeden Fall Shooting Star Kajetan Lenz, wurde ja heute auch verkündet, dass er jetzt nach Hoffenheim gehen wird. Du hast ihn schon genannt, Francis Onyeka vielleicht noch, und Philipp Hofmann haben wir erwähnt, und Kojimi Yoshi. Ja, und dann wird es für mich ehrlicherweise schon sehr dünn. Ich weiß nicht, ob, ne? Also ich finde, es ist halt eine Mischung aus einem Trainer, der in gewissen Situationen, um das Team zu stabilisieren, da ist er sehr, sehr gut. Aber um jetzt vielleicht was Neues aufzubauen, das war zumindest meine Erfahrung in Düsseldorf, vielleicht nicht die ideale Wahl. Und dann eben ein Kader, der nicht gut zusammengestellt ist. Ich glaube, das muss man ganz klar so sagen. Auch hier war ja das Zielaufstieg zu Saisonbeginn. Da hat man sich ähnlich vertan wie in Düsseldorf, muss man sagen. Da fehlt es dann, also klar, Philipp Hofmann ist da im Sturm, aber die meisten anderen Offensivkräfte und Stürmer haben nicht überzeugt diese Saison. Und Hofmann war ja gerade zu Saisonbeginn noch gar nicht fit. Du hattest es eben schon mal, glaube ich, kurz angedeutet. Also da fehlte es gerade, aber auch dann eben an spielerischen Ideen. Ich meine, es ist ein großes Glück, dass Onjeka eingeschlagen ist, aber der kam, glaube ich, als 19-Jährige aus Leverkusen als Leihspieler. Da gibt es überhaupt keine Garantien. Leute wie Matos Spiero, Kapitän und slowakischer Nationalspieler, für mich eine komplett enttäuschende Saison. Er hat natürlich auch zwischendurch etwas länger verletzt. Also ich glaube, dieser Kader braucht einfach wirklich– und er wird auch kommen, weil natürlich auch einige Leihspieler dabei sind, aber der braucht eine Grundauffrischung. Und dann muss man sich halt die Trainerfrage stellen, ob man mit Röstar weitermachen möchte, ihm das zutraut oder eben nicht.
Ja, ich gehe vielleicht erst einmal rein. Nur, dass er ganz am Anfang die Frage gestellt, quasi so ein bisschen die Rollen vertauscht. Ja, also es ist– ich glaube, das war ja genau das, was wir– also die Bochum nicht als Ausstiegskandidaten getippt hatten zu Beginn der Saison. Genau, das war damals schon so mein Kritikpunkt. Also einmal, Anna, du hast es im Vorgespräch gesagt, die Dialogging hat man irgendwie so ein bisschen verdrängt. Und natürlich liegt eben viel an Dirktuf naht, dass das nicht alles in der Winterpause behoben werden konnte, war auch klar. Nicht jeder kann so erfolgreiche Transfers auch aus einer, ich sage mal, Position der Euphorie hertätigen wie Schalke 04, wo man ja wirklich sagen muss, also neben Oshish, Lovicic, Deku ist das schon wirklich schwierig, wenn du sonst so ne Neuzugang im Winter warst. Aber ich finde es halt interessant, weil ich erinnere mich noch sehr gut daran, dass wir zur Hinrundenbilanz. Gab es eben ein Kommentar eines Bochumer Fans, der eben gesagt hat, dass ja alles schön und gut, was Rösler geschafft hat jetzt in der Hinrunde und wir haben uns stabilisiert und wir sind aus dieser akuten Abstiegsgefahr hin raus. Aber er erwartet von ihm halt, dass jetzt diese Quick-Fixes vorbei sind. Und man muss halt dann ehrlich sagen, ich gehe mal davon aus, genau die gleiche Voraussetzung gab es intern auch. Also wie sieht denn die Rückrunde aus? Wie sieht da die Entwicklung aus? Und da finde ich dann schon, dass du es eben nicht nur alleine am Kader festmachen kannst. Weil, also, wie gesagt, du hattest dieses 2-0 gegen Dresden, wo Dresden einfach im Gegensatz zu dem Fortuna-Spiel in einer ganz anderen Position war. Und wie gesagt, man muss hier in diesem Spiel einfach mal sagen, eigentlich musst du führt in dieses, also, du musst entweder viel früher das 3-0 machen. Aber ich hatte auch so das Gefühl, nach dem Abseitstor dachten sie auch so, ja, aber es ist ja gefallen, das Tor. Also, es zählt jetzt zwar nicht, aber was soll denn jetzt noch groß passieren? Und das, also, das fand ich ganz, ganz fatal. Und man muss wirklich fragen, ob eine andere Mannschaft da in dem Tag sie nicht mehr wirklich bestraft hätte. Und sie haben jetzt eben selber sich diesen Matchball hingelegt. Man hat 6 Punkte auf einem direkten Abstiegsplatz. Man kann gegen Bielefeld am Wochenende den Klassen halt faktisch klar machen. Aber ich sag mal so, wenn du doch spielst gegen, wie gegen Dresden und führt, Bielefeld, reden wir gleich auch nochmal drüber. Dann wird das, glaube ich, nicht so der Selbstläufer, wie die denken, dass das wird. Anna?
Sie hatten ja einfach diese Momente, in denen sie vom Gegner wirklich arg, arg, arg da unten in diesen Tabellenbereich hätten reingezogen werden können. Sie schlagen Eintracht Braunschweig 4 zu 1 zu Hause. In der Summe absolut in Ordnung. War kein gutes Spiel von der Braunschweiger Eintracht auf der einen Seite, auf der anderen Seite. War ich so ein bisschen ratlos über die großen Euphorie-Stürme des Kommentators über diesen großartigen Fußball, weil ich einfach das Gefühl hatte, der Ball fliegt nach vorne und da ist dann eben Philipp Hofmann. Also was soll man machen? Und wäre konjunktiv, wenn wir dieses Spiel gewonnen hätten, dann wären die eben richtig tief wieder mit dabei gewesen, weil sie davor gegen Abstiegskonkurrenz Magdeburg und Kiel verloren haben. Und ich habe so ein bisschen den Eindruck, dass die Mannschaft– das passt vielleicht auch zu dem, was du gerade beschrieben hast– sich so ein bisschen auch für too big, too fail hält. Weiß ich nicht genau, dafür habe ich zu wenig in Gänze gesehen. Könnte mir aber vorstellen, dass– also ja, dass das– weil sonst machst du da den Deckel drauf. Und eierst da, eierst diese Partie nicht so zu Ende, weil Föhrt ja grundsätzlich auch sogar noch ausgleichen kann. Aber vielleicht zählt es auch auf das, was Thorsten vorhin über seine Fortuna gesagt hat. Nimmst du es wirklich so richtig, richtig ernst? Hast du wirklich im Kopf, dass du da unten richtig tief mit reinrutschen kannst? Kennst du die Dynamik, die dann zum Tragen kommt? Ich weiß es nicht. Da müssen vereins nähere Personen das bewerten. Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass bei den Namen, die dort auf dem Platz stehen, man annimmt, dass es einem sowieso nicht passiert.
Ja, finde ich sehr interessant, weil ich kenne die Situation ja einfach mit Bielefeld von vor drei Jahren, wo man dann auch immer irgendwann dachte, too big, too fail, so nach dem Motto. Es sind sechs Punkte, und ich sage es gerne auch nochmal, aber was zum Beispiel auch hier ist, sie haben halt einen Plus-Eins-Tor-Verhältnis, das unterscheidet sie zu sehr vielen Vereinen da unten. Aber wenn du sie halt zum Beispiel mit Dresden und Bielefeld und so mixt, ist das halt dann doch nicht wieder so gut. Und dann musst du halt am Ende sagen, na klar, klingt doch ein Platz 10 schon noch besser als ein Platz 14 am Ende der Saison zum Beispiel. Und also ich kann da, ich habe den schon öfter mal in dieser Saison empfohlen, den 1848-Blog. Da hängt auch ein Podcast dran, aber ich finde vor allem den Blog sehr gut. Und die eben auch in dem Spielbericht, den habe ich euch verlinkt in den Show notes zu diesem Spiel, eben genau auch diese Fragen stellen. Wie geht es denn eigentlich weiter? Und jetzt eben auch eben mit Blick auf die Partie von Bochum und Bielefeld gesagt haben, also vor diesem Spieltag war übrigens Bielefeld die schlechteste Auswärtsmannschaft der Liga. Das ist alles sehr nah da unten beieinander. Aber also das Hinspiel, das war ein furchtbares Fußballspiel, wo Bochum eben am Ende durch diese individuelle Klasse, die sie dann halt doch anders hatten als Bielefeld, gewonnen hat. Aber ja, also danach geht es halt gegen Hannover und KSC. KSC ist so, die machen entweder das oder das gerade. Die haben vielleicht, wollen eben Eichner einen guten Abschluss liefern, glaube ich auch einfach.
Und es ist auswärts, also nicht zu Hause gegen Karlsruhe, sondern auswärts.
Und das finde ich, also mir, also ich gehe da zum Beispiel auch mit, Anna. Ich finde, also den Kommentator, also ich habe da sowieso immer ein Problem damit. Das liegt natürlich auch qua meiner Vereinszugehörigkeit, kann ich dem VfL Bochum per se relativ wenig abgewinnen. Aber es war dann auch so, ja, Philipp Hofmann, der Harry Kane, der der 2.
Liga.
Und ich war inzwischen so, ja, okay, da war jetzt an 8 Toren beteiligt in den letzten vier Spielen. Und ja, du merkst, wenn er nicht da ist. Aber uff, so. Und dann halt auch irgendwie dieser Vergleich zu dem Marathonläufer, der an dem Tag unter zwei Stunden. Ja, ich bin mir sicher, wenn man Philipp Hofmann da jetzt hinstellen würde, der würde auch unter zwei Stunden laufen. Ich weiß nicht, also Philipp Hofmann war jetzt nicht so bekannt als schnellster Spieler der 2. Bundesliga. Gut, ich kann halt sowas. Und dafür habe ich dann nämlich auch manchmal das Gefühl, dass das der Blick nach außen dann auch trügt, weil ich hatte nämlich auch nicht das Gefühl, weder vom Publikum her noch von der Mannschaft auf dem Rasen, dass da so richtig angekommen ist, dass das Ding hier noch nicht durch ist. Und das kann halt einfach richtig, richtig gefährlich werden. Und wie gesagt, ich sage es nochmal, es gibt jetzt am Wochenende eben diese Partie gegen Bielefeld. Sie haben bisher dann am Ende immer die nötigen Punkte geholt. Aber man muss natürlich dann trotzdem auch sagen, inwiefern spielt der Abstieg aus der letzten Saison, das ist jetzt eher so eine psychologische Frage, bei manchen Spielern dann vielleicht auch nochmal eine Rolle. So, weil das ist halt, also wie gesagt, ich gehe per se nicht davon aus, dass der Vorfall Bochum noch absteigt. Also, um nochmal klarzumachen, ich bin weiterhin der Meinung, die sind gesichert. Aber das, was sie eben beide auch schon gesagt haben, so ein bisschen, haben sie sich auch darauf ausgesucht, dass sie in dieser Position waren. Und das dürfen sie halt am Wochenende, also meinetwegen können sie das ja gerne machen, dürfen sie natürlich aus rein sportlicher Sicht natürlich auf gar keinen Fall machen. Und das ist halt, ja, also natürlich ist das auch gut, weil Philipp Hofmann in einer gewissen Weise, er steht dann da halt auch, aber persiv finde ich zum Beispiel auch da, das konnte man zum Teil auch mehr mit der führter Defensive, die wieder so ein bisschen außerwiegender Hinrunde erklären, als dass das jetzt reine bochumer taktische Meisterleistung war.
Definitiv, also das ist auch mein Eindruck aus dem Spiel gegen Braunschweig, das ich leider komplett gesehen habe, dass das jetzt nicht ein glänzendes 4-1-Galer-Stück gewesen ist, sondern dass der Gegner sehr schlecht war und dass das individuell an dem Tag einfach gepasst hat, weil zwei Spieler gesagt haben, wir betonieren jetzt unseren Ex-Verein. Liebe Grüße, vielen Dank. Das war sehr unangenehm. Aber nicht besonders schön. Sorry to say.
Wir haben Bochum in beiden Spielen besiegt. Darum kenne ich sie sowieso nur als unterlegenes Team.
Natürlich.
Eins von zwei Teams. Diese Saison gibt mir wirklich wenig. Das andere ist Paderborn. Also unsere beiden Schwerpunkt-Teams, die wir beide besiegt haben. Mit Fürth können wir es noch schaffen. Aber ja, ich bin da bei euch. Und wie gesagt, für mich ist aber auch spannend die Frage. Und ich glaube, ehrlicherweise auch, weil einfach zu viele Teams dazwischen sind auch, die sich ja die Punkte auch gegenseitig wegnehmen will, sagen, die können nicht alle gleichzeitig gewinnen in den letzten drei Spielen, dass für Bochum wahrscheinlich nichts mehr anbrennen wird. Und dann stellt sich halt für mich wirklich die Frage, wie geht es bei Bochum weiter? Das finde ich ist eine sehr spannende Frage nächsten Sommer, weil auch das Stadion ja umgebaut wird. Und wir haben es ja gerade festgestellt, also die Heimstärke ist da. Und aus neutraler Sicht ist das auch eins der cooleren Stadien der Liga. Da würde mir wahrscheinlich niemand widersprechen, dass es vielleicht doch ein bisschen cooler ist in Bochum als in Elbersberg. Sorry an alle Elbersberg-Fans.
Ich möchte nur noch mal sagen, ich möchte weiterhin keine Umbau von irgendwelchen Stadien bezahlen. Also weil ich sage nochmal 42,50 für diese Sitzplätze.
Jetzt wird hier jetzt umgebaut. Für 91,9 Millionen.
Sie sagen, es ist das beste Stadion NRWs oder so.
Naja, der Zustand nicht, aber es hat natürlich einen gewissen Scham. Das würde ich dem Stadion durchaus zugestehen. Die Sanitäranlagen sollen auch… Also vielleicht gibt es demnächst mal Pissoirs. Das wäre mal was aus männlicher Sicht, um hier mal aus dem Neck zu plaudern. Da habe ich gleich… Ja, genau. Gar nicht ganz genau. Unangenehm. Unangenehm, ja. Das kann man ja sagen.
Für ihn eine gute Nachhau.
Aber das liegt darauf, das Stadion wird teilweise auf eine Kapazität von nur 18.000 zurückfallen in den nächsten drei Jahren. Das kann sich natürlich auch negativ auswirken. Wir haben gerade eben ja festgestellt, dass der VfL dieses Stadion durchaus braucht. Und man wird also auch sehen, auch sowas ist nicht zwingend ein Vorteil, zumal der ganze Stadionumbau, dem VfL eigentlich nur etwas moderneres, aber nicht gerade ein einnahmetechnisch verbessertes Stadion liefern wird, was man so hört. Ja, also viel im Umbruch im Bochum, glaube ich, kann man zusammenfassen.
Sie werden nächste Saison, ich glaube, da sind wir uns jetzt alle eigentlich weiterhin, eine Rolle in diesem Podcast spielen. Bevor wir jetzt auf unsere letzten beiden Vereine kommen und dann Anna und ich noch so ein bisschen, weiß ich nicht, gute Laune, vielleicht auch per se schlechte Laune, wissen wir, glaube ich, noch nicht so ganz verbreiten können, kommen wir zu unserer Feedback-Schleife. Erstmal vielen lieben Dank für das ganze positive Feedback zur letzten Folge. Also es war quasi, spiegelte das wieder, was wir trotz der angekündigten schlechten Launefolge hatten. Und sorry nochmal, dass das so lange gedauert hat, bis das Video um war. Ja, manchmal hasst mich die Technik einfach. Ich kann euch leider immer noch nicht so zu 100 Prozent sagen, woran das gelegen hat, was einen immer tierisch beruhigt. Sonst ist natürlich der Hinweis, ihr kennt es. Der Rasenfunk ist und bleibt werbe-, paywall- und sponsorenfrei. Wir finanzieren uns ausschließlich dadurch, dass ihr uns unterstützt unter www.rasenfunk.de/supportusclub. Da könnt ihr euch darüber informieren, wie man eben supporter wird. Mehr Infos auch in den Show Notes. Und auf der Webseite seht ihr eben auch nochmal eine Aufteilung. Also da gibt es auch einen Unterstützen-Button. Da könnt ihr euch auch ganz schnell dadurch registrieren. Und ihr könnt da tatsächlich auch sehen, inwieweit das, was ihr spendet, eben an Prozenten in die verschiedenen Bereiche fließt. Zum Beispiel, wie viel an Prozenten an Marc und mich gehen, an unsere Gäste, an den Rasenfunk an sich. Also wenn ihr es noch nicht seid, dann überlegt doch, ob ihr das werdet. Und vor allem auch im Hinblick darauf, was Max schon wieder abgeliefert hat. Also es sind Sendungen zur Bundesliga der Männer und Frauen erschienen. Vor allem die Sendung der Frauen, die hat dann mal wieder alleine gewuppt, mal ebenso zwischendurch in diesen Spieltag rein. War eine kurze Sendung, es sind nur zwei Stunden. Also ich finde, also zwei Stunden Monolog von Max, was kann es besseres geben? Außerdem ist letzte Woche eine Ligatour zu den europäischen Ligen erschienen. Und am Donnerstag, da erscheint dann vielleicht für viele Fans der lange erwartete Schwerpunkt zum VfB Stuttgart. Sonst hier natürlich auch nochmal der Hinweis, ich freue mich sehr über Input, Input-Thread zu den Zweitligatouren. Da seid ihr auch immer fleißig am Schreiben dabei. Da mag ich eigentlich auch sehr, wie eben diskutiert wird. Man haltet das gerne bei. Gibt manchmal auch Jörn Blickwinkel auf die Themen, die man so vielleicht nicht hatte. Und natürlich auch vielen Dank für eure Hinweise immer zum Feedback. Deshalb ich hoffe an die Person, die geschrieben hat, ich lese, verlese die Zahlen zu schnell. Ich hoffe, es war jetzt besser. Und du kannst besser deine Hausarbeit erledigen, nebenher. Sorry, ich ratte das immer so ein bisschen runter. Auch in der Angst, dass ich mich sonst verspreche, was nicht so ganz logisch klingt. Aber naja, ja, wie komme ich jetzt von Angst auf den nächsten Verein? Es geht um Aminia Bielefeld. Es ist Platz 13, 35 Punkte, 46 zu 47 Tore, 9 Siege, 8 Unentschieden und 14 Niederlagen. In der Formtabelle ist man auf Platz 9, 2 Siege, 1 Unentschieden und 2 Niederlagen. Nach der klaren Niederlage gegen Karlsruhe folgte ein merkwürdiges Spiel gegen Nürnberg, was am Ende 1 zu 1 ausging. Und jetzt am Wochenende der Derby-Sieg gegen Münster. Nach einem frühen 0-1-Rückstand, dann mit drei Toren in 23 Minuten. Da war mal wieder diese Selbstverständlichkeit da eigentlich, die man mal entwickelt hat im Laufe der Saison. Nach Führung dann auch mal mehr zu treffen. Und endlich drei Tore aus Standard- beziehungsweise Standard-ähnlichen Situationen. Ich sag jetzt schon mal, also mein Tor des Monats ist da gefallen. Ich wusste nicht. Also man muss dazu sagen, mal Corbis vergibt sehr kläglich aus fünf Metern gerne mal vom Tor, aber einen Hackentrick, den kann er dann auspacken zum 3-1. Aber es wäre nicht Amina Bielefeld, wenn man es zum Ende nicht nochmal spannend macht. In der zweiten Halbzeit war das, ja ich sag mal, für die Bielefelder Seele nicht so ganz angenehm zu gucken. Macht am Ende eben noch einen Eigentor von Maxi Großer für zum 2-3. Bielefeld mit den meisten Rückständen der Liga, aber wenigstens noch 19 Punkte geholt, 4 Siege, 7 Remis. Nach 14 Führungen 9 Mal gewonnen übrigens, 1 Remis, 4 Niederlagen. Ja, also ich kann ja einmal ganz kurz nur sagen, dass man wusste vor diesem Spiel, der Druck ist groß. Also ich kann aus Bielefelder Sicht sagen, nach diesem 1-1 gegen Nürnberg, also diese Partien, Karlsruhe, Nürnberg war bei sehr, sehr vielen Fans. Eigentlich genau der Schritt in die falsche Richtung. Da hatte man echt so ein bisschen das Gefühl, okay, ist euch irgendwie bewusst, wo ihr seid und was hier gerade eigentlich passiert. Und man muss sagen, also klar, man gerät früh in Rückstand, aber die Reaktion, die die Mannschaft auf diesen Rückstand gezeigt hat, die war wirklich bemerkenswert. Und das war auch so ein bisschen das, was man aus der Mannschaft daraus gehört hat. Und jetzt natürlich aber, Anna, ich würde dich mal als erstes fragen, also ihr seid ja beide eher daran interessiert, dass Bielefeld jetzt nicht punktet, das ist mir auch durchaus bewusst. Ja, ja, ihr wollt den Host hier nicht verärgern, ist schon klar.
Dass du mir so was unterstellst. Von mir kam nie ein böses Wort.
Aber Anna, vielleicht mal von dir erstmal, wie würdest du denn diesen Sieg jetzt am Wochenende gegen Münster aus Bielefelder Sicht bewerten?
Es ist natürlich ein Brett. Ich habe ja das Wochenende nicht nur in Kaiserslautern verbracht, sondern auch in Karlsruhe. Und dort meinen Lebens- und Derby-Partner zum Spiel gegen den KSD begleitet. Auch sehr gute Beinschorle übrigens im Weltpark. Mit mehr Wasser aber.
Welche war besser?
Kommt auf die Parameter an. Wumms in Kaiserslautern, erfrischender Karlsruhe. The true is your fighter. Und genau, in der größeren Gruppe unterwegs gewesen und irgendwann schlicht sich dann das Gedankenspiel ein, wie es sich wohl anfühlen würde, im Abstiegskampf einen Derby spielen zu müssen, bei dem beide im Abstiegskampf einfach relevant involviert sind und ich möchte das auf gar keinen Fall. Das stelle ich mir wirklich uneingeschränkt schrecklich vor. Weil da sich irgendwie alles kombiniert, was man eben nicht haben möchte. Also du möchtest sowieso kein Derby verlieren und du möchtest jetzt auf gar keinen Fall durch eine Nidhida-Galllage im Derby noch tiefer in den Abstiegskampf gezogen werden oder sogar, dass es am Ende heißt, in diesem Moment stand der Abstieg fest. Und ich kann mir vorstellen, dass da ganz, ganz, ganz üble Gedankenspiele im Kopf waren, als Münster dann in Führung gegangen ist. Zumal Münster jetzt nach dem Trainerwechsel, darüber haben wir in der letzten Rasenfunk-Folge ja gesprochen, nicht unbedingt für furioses Torschießfeuerwerk steht, sondern eher für grundlegende Defensivarbeit und dann konzentriertes Vorgehen. Und in meinem Kopf wäre gewesen, okay, wir verlieren jetzt hier mit einem Gegentor und null eigenen Toren, tschau. Und ja, wie gesagt, also mein vollstes Mitgefühl dafür. Wir haben schon über diesen Schlusschor gesprochen. Bielefeld ist Derbysieger, finde ich super fantastisch. Ich möchte jetzt diesen Münster-Fangesang nicht zitieren, weil es ein Wort enthält, das ich nicht öffentlich sagen möchte. Aber genau, die Nachlese da gerne, die Stimmen nach dem Spiel sind bei YouTube zu hören und der Bielefelder Chor im Hintergrund. Ich glaube, dann ist die Verbindung klar. Ich glaube, dass das total viel machen kann, weil Bielefeld ja kommt aus dem Aufstieg nicht nur, sondern aus dem Pokalfinale. Und ich mir vorstellen kann, dass dieses Schulterschlussgefühl jetzt im Saisonfinale super, super, super wichtig ist, weil ihr ja eigentlich im Hinblick auf– also auf jeden Fall Vereinsmitglieder, vielleicht auch Dauerkartenverkäufe, Fragezeichen, kannst du gleich was zu sagen, wenn man die Topzahlen hat und unerreicht irgendwie bisher eigene Rekorde bricht. Und ich kann mir vorstellen, dass das jetzt irgendwie wieder der X-Faktor sein wird, der vor Beginn oder zum Beginn der Saison dafür gesorgt hat, dass der Start ja super war. Und dass das jetzt vielleicht einfach so ein bisschen den Kreis schließt, da wieder anzuknüpfen und dass man daran erinnert worden ist, an diesem letzten Spieltag.
Ja, das ist ganz interessant, weil dieser Zusammenschluss ist ja das, was eigentlich schon seit einer sehr langen Zeit eigentlich schon, als man quasi mit einem Bein in der 4. Liga stand, ist dieser dieser Slogan zusammen halt triumfiert. Und das ist, also man muss das in Bielefeld, ich habe das schon mal gesagt, aber wirklich auch, wir haben halt diesen Vergleich, diese Saison von vor drei Jahren, wo du eben am Ende abgestiegen bist, auch weil du am letzten Spiel gegen Magdeburg halt irgendwie komplett seelenlos 04 verlierst und dann kommen diese Relegationsspiele gegen Wiesbaden. Und du merkst einfach, das war halt ab diesem Abstieg sehr vielen Bielefeld-Fans wichtig und ich glaube, das war dem Verein auch wichtig. Wir müssen irgendwie alle wieder zusammenarbeiten. Und man muss halt sagen, das ist gleichzeitig Stärke und natürlich auch ein Problem, weil wie willst du Mannschaft und vielleicht auch Fans verklickern nach diesem Aufstieg, nach dem Pokalfinale? Wir müssen diese Mannschaft jetzt auseinanderreißen, weil die Hälfte von denen, ob die jetzt 2. Liga-tauglich ist, don't know. Und du siehst das, also ich möchte das überhaupt nicht kleinreden, du siehst natürlich in Spielen in dieser Saison, dass ein Teil dieses Teams einfach nicht 2. Liga-tauglich ist. Das muss man, glaube ich, einfach wirklich so bescheinigen. Ich muss an der Stelle, auch weil es ein bisschen im Forum aufkam, ehrlich gesagt ein paar Bielefeld-Fans auch kritisieren, weil ich von dieser Hühn-Hot-Kultur relativ wenig halte. Also im Sommer war nach den zwei Siegen zu Beginn alles toll. Jetzt ist irgendwie alles scheiße und man hat im Sommer nur falsche Entscheidungen getroffen und so wieso. Und mit Knien halt bis zum Ende der Saison und Tiestas. Und hier Kersken macht in jedem Spiel einen Fehler. Halte ich für genau den falschen Weg, ehrlich gesagt, weil ich sage das gerne nochmal. Es ist manchmal einfacher, als Mannschaft aufzusteigen und sich dann neu zu formieren. Weil zum Beispiel bei Dynamo Dresden war es dann schon einfacher, vielleicht im Winter zwei, drei Spieler neu zu integrieren, als es bei Aminia Bielefeld der Fall war. Und trotzdem, ne, und das ist halt einfach schwierig. Dann verletzt sich noch ein Joel Felix, dann würde hier irgendwie geschrieben, ja, Bielefeld macht seinen Zusammenhalt kaputt, weil er Knoche und Bauer koffen, wo ich es ganz klar sagen muss. Also sollen wir einfach mit einem Innenverteidiger die restliche Saison spielen? Oder wie stellen die Leute sich das vor? Und das ist wirklich so ein bisschen mein Kritikpunkt, weil ich habe dann heute gesehen, dass jemand aufgelistet hat, die Fehler welcher Spieler in welchem Spiel gemacht hat. Das finde ich drei Spieltage vor Schluss nach dem Derbysieg genau das falsche Zeichen, weil das bringt uns jetzt nichts, weil genau das, worüber wir am Wochenende gekommen sind, also wir, sage ich, die Mannschaft, aber eben auch der Zusammenschluss, Fans, Team auf dem Rasen, das ist das, wo du jetzt die letzten drei Spiele eben machen musst. Und das finde ich sehr merkwürdig und gerade auch, also ich verstehe zum Teil die Kritik an Jonas Kersgen, aber ich möchte das trotzdem nochmal sagen, für einen Großteil dieser Mannschaft war das das erste 2. Liga-Jahr. Ja, und die sind zum Teil auch in einem gehobenen Alter, das ist gemischt, dass da nicht alle gleich die Saison ihres Lebens spielen. Okay, so. Und gerade finde ich die Kritik an Jonas Kersgen nach diesem Wochenende ehrlich gesagt nicht angebracht, weil meiner Meinung nach ist Kersgen, als der Rest der Mannschaft so ein bisschen gepennt hat hinten, der hat Bielefeld zweitermal im Spiel gehalten. Ja, er sieht da nicht gut aus beim 2 zu 3, aber ohne ihn stellen es halt vorher vielleicht schon ein entschieden. So. Das ist einfach mein Appell, also sorry für den Rant und sorry für mein Monolog gerade, aber das ist tatsächlich mein Appell an die restlichen Aminia-Fans. Wir können im Sommer alles neu bewerten. Und ich bin der festen Überzeugung, genau das wird Michael Mutzel machen, es wird auch Mitch Kniehart machen, da werden schon, also wenn sie es nicht machen, dann können wir da nochmal drüber diskutieren, aber ich habe, ich verstehe nicht so ganz, wonach in den letzten drei Jahren oder zwei Jahren oder drei Jahren dieses tiefe Misstrauen auf einmal herkommt. Und das finde ich tatsächlich sehr gefährlich und einfach wie gesagt finde ich unangebracht. Ich habe gleich noch einen zweiten Rantpunkt, aber ich möchte einmal erst Thorsten dazu holen, um vielleicht noch mal so ein bisschen die Runde zu schließen. Ich war ja bei euch zu Gast zu Beginn der Rückrunde und da haben wir ja eigentlich gesagt, ja Bielefeld, die werden vielleicht jetzt nicht genau die gleiche Punkte holen, nicht die gleichen Spiele gewinnen wie in der Hinrunde. Aber die werden schon ihre Punkte holen. Jetzt muss man sagen, man hat jetzt in der Rückrunde 16 Punkte bisher geholt. In der Hinrunde waren es 19 insgesamt. Wie würdest du denn per se auf Bielefeld gucken? Was macht dir vielleicht auch aus neutraler Sicht, was sagst du, was sind jetzt die Punkte, die im Endspurt helfen?
Also grundsätzlich finde ich nach wie vor, dass Aminia Bielefeld häufig zumindest was Seriöses anbietet. Also ihr faltet auch irgendwie selten auseinander oder so etwas, oder dass man das Gefühl hat, diese Mannschaft ist jetzt nicht mit dem Herzen dabei. Also gerade mindset, die soften Fakten, die stimmen bei der Aminia. Und ich glaube auch, dass mit Kniet einfach ein sehr guter Fit ist und dass das passt. Er hat ja auch ein ganz interessantes Spielsystem, was ja manchmal so fast ein bisschen chaotisch wirkt, aber immer noch natürlich hohe Intensität gegen Pressing und so weiter. Wenn man sich die Werte auch anguckt bei Bielefeld, da seid ihr wirklich ganz weit oben. Gefühlt können die Ergebnisse manchmal nicht mithalten. Und das ist, glaube ich, genau das, was du gesagt hast. Weiter fehlt es hier und da ein bisschen nicht nur an 2. Liga-Erfahrung, sondern vielleicht auch an Qualität. Es gibt so ein paar Leute, die herausragen jetzt– zuletzt ja Monjuo Momolo– sehr auffällig. Und der gefällt mir auch wirklich super. Es fehlt so ein bisschen bei euch der Torjäger vorne drin. Also klar, Grudowsky hat seine neun Tore als schneller Umschaltstürmer, aber ist nicht so ein Zielspieler wie Hofmann, wie Itten oder Ähnliches, die einem da vielleicht auch noch mal ein bisschen weiterhelfen. Das ist schon ein Defizit. Und ich muss auch sagen, so richtig gut hat das Winter-Transfer-Fenster aus meiner Sicht dann nicht geklappt. Also ja, Knoche ist aus meiner Sicht wirklich eine Verstärkung, finde ich. Hat euch da sehr stabilisiert. Maximilian Bauer sehe ich schon seit seiner Lauternzeit eher immer etwas kritischer. Und ja, Telalovic, ich glaube, er hat neulich jetzt endlich mal sein Tor gemacht, aber ist ein Spieler, bei dem ich mir aktuell nicht so ganz sicher bin, ob er wirklich ein Zweitligamann ist. Und auch Rochelt wartet jetzt schon sehr lange auf eine wirklich gute Halbserie mal wieder. Vielleicht hast du da noch ein bisschen andere Meinung, dass er jetzt langsam kommt oder so. Aber ich sag mal so, ihr hattet jetzt nicht so ein Winter-Transferfenster wie Dynamo Dresden. Und wenn wir auf die Hinrunde gucken, wo ja Dresden ganz klar schlechter als Bielefeld war in praktisch allen Belangen, muss man sagen, weil ihr beide auch die Aufsteiger seid und man das ein bisschen vergleichen kann, da hat Dresden im Winter es geschafft, die Qualität etwas höher zu steigern, als das bei Bielefeld der Fall war. Und gefühlt stimmt es aber eigentlich von außen betrachtet an so vielen Stellen, dass es eigentlich wirklich sehr tragisch wäre, wenn das am Ende irgendwie in einem Abstieg münden würde, weil genau wie du gesagt hast, gefühlt wird da gerade was aufgebaut wieder in Bielefeld, was kaputtgegangen war. Und Aufbau, das weiß man im Fußball, braucht Zeit, auch wenn man die nie hat. Und darum kann ich deinen Appell an die Leute oder Bielefeld-Fans schon verstehen. Man ist eben jetzt nicht automatisch durch den Wiederaufstieg wieder eine Mannschaft, die höhere Ambitionen als Klassenerhalt feiern kann. Dafür schlagen so zwei Jahre in der 3. Liga auch allein finanziell so sehr ins Kontor. Das muss man erstmal wieder aufholen. Ich glaube, Braunschweig kennt das Gefühl auch. Ich hoffe, dass uns dieser Cage erspart bleibt. Weil da einfach sehr viel kaputt geht. Darum, ja, es wird nicht einfach, weil immer wieder so ein bisschen diese Spiele dabei sind, wo man sagt, das Ergebnis, dieses 1-1 gegen Nürnberg, ich habe es nur in der Zusammenfassung gesehen, aber war wohl scheinbar kein gutes Spiel in irgendeiner Form. Man spürt der Mannschaft wahrscheinlich auch so ein bisschen den Druck. Also man merkt ja das an, aber was ich eingangs sagte, ich finde, die Einstellung stimmt eigentlich von außen betrachtet immer bei Bielefeld. Das ist ja ein Thema, das hatten wir eben, das ist vielleicht bei Bochum oder Düsseldorf, bei anderen im Abstiegskampf nicht immer so der Fall und das kann am Ende vielleicht dann auch noch den Ausschlag geben.
Ja, so ein bisschen positiv hat mich tatsächlich gestimmt, dass man jetzt eben zwei Spiele vom Ergebnis her anders gestalten konnte als in der Hinrunde. Also man hat eben die Partie, die war ähnlich furchtbar in der Hinrunde, die Partie gegen Nürnberg, aber die hat man eben 2 zu 0 verloren. Hier konnte man eben, also am Ende war mir relativ egal, wie man dieses 1-1, also dieses Unentschieden holt. Ich finde, dann ist halt tatsächlich immer wichtig, ja, Aussagen, die nach außen getroffen werden, auch nicht immer gut, aber wie wird das intern aufgearbeitet. Und da hatte ich eben schon das Gefühl, dass da, genauso wie im Karlsruhe-Spiel, dann in der Zweieinhalbstatt schon die Einstellungen-Problem war. Und das war eben, also, hätte die Einstellung nicht gepasst in dieser Partie gegen Münster, dann verlierst du das eben genauso, Anna, wie du es eben beschrieben hast. Und das war eben nicht der Fall. Und Mal Corvus hat zum Beispiel auch gesagt, also da war es eben auch, da waren Fans beim Training. Es gab eben auch vor dem Spiel nochmal dieses Einschwören mit der Mannschaft, vor dem Block, das spielt dann eben schon einen Unterschied. Und dann war das Derby wahrscheinlich dann doch nochmal so ein positiver Kick. Du hast jetzt am Wochenende aus mehreren Gründen eben das nächste Highlight-Spiel. Also eben ist Bochum eben auch so ein Nordrhein-Westfalen-Derby. Let's Fight, sag's doch! Nee, also es hat auch was damit zu tun. Wer es nicht weiß, Bochum und Münster auflegen eine Fan-Freundschaft. Also das heißt, und Bielefeld und Münster sind eben verhasst, kann man glaube ich schon so sagen. Und das ist deshalb schon so ein Prestigeting, vor allem, weil man eben beide Partien in der Hinrunde verloren hat. Und da hast du dann auch gesehen, da hat es dann auch das SMA-Fan-Technisch so ein bisschen gekippt, weil du eben diese Spiele willst halt nicht verlieren. Es steht dann eben auch noch der 121. Geburtstag an. Und es ist 100-jähriges Juwiläum der Alm. Also seit 1926 gibt es eben das Stadion Alm. Es heißt seit 2004 Schiko-Arena. Es nennt es niemand so, außer Aminia in ihrer offiziellen Kommunikation. Das ist ein Rabbit Hole. Also ich könnte mich tierisch darüber aufregen, dass überall, also es wurde groß angekündigt, ja für den Tag heißt das Stadion wieder Alm. Aber dann heißt es überall, ja hier hinten auf den Trikots und so, Stadion an der Mainland-Schütternstraße und unser Zuhause. Ich finde es ganz furchtbar. Es ist wirklich, ja, ist für mich mehr Marketing-Kniff als wirklich ernst gemeinte Hommage an die Fans, was ich wirklich sehr schade finde. Aber man hat jetzt eben das Heimspiel gegen Bochum, dann Aussitz bei Kaiserslautern und dann Zuhause bei der Hertha. Und das waren eben in der Hinrundespiele, da hat man eben nur zwei Punkte geholt. Dieses ganz furchtbare 0-0 gegen Kaiserslautern und dieses 1-1 gegen Hertha, wo Russo da eben in der 90. Plus 6, glaube ich, noch dieses Ding reinschraubt. Da bin ich sehr, sehr gespannt, was wir da im sehen. Aber da muss man eben sagen, Anna, du hattest eben, glaube ich, gefragt, wegen Zuschauertalen, Mitglieder und so. Also, man muss sagen, dann stand jetzt, weil jedes Heimspiel heimseitig ausverkauft. Es gibt eben 17.000 Dauerkarten, das wurde am Anfang gedeckelt. Und man ist inzwischen bei einer Mitgliedszahl über 30.000. Das ist eben schon... Die Rekorde sind da. Natürlich weiß man nicht, wie viele bleiben übrig, aber wir haben das erstmal eine Warteliste für Dauerkarten und so. Also, das ist schon... Der Hype war die ganze Saison trotzdem über da. Also, ne, das war schon echt krass. Und natürlich für mich ist es noch so ein kleiner Innenminster. Man hat... Es ist ja gerade ein Neubau, ich möchte noch mal sagen. Für alle, die nach Münster auswärtsfahren müssen, demnächst, vielleicht auch in der 3. Liga, man weiß es nicht. Es ist schon sehr irritierend, dass vor dem Stehplatzbereich sind noch mal Drehkreuze. Vom Sitzplatzbereich nicht. Also, da musst du noch mal dein Ticket einscannen, fürs Reihen und fürs Rausgehen. Zwar gibt es auch ein Tor, aber ich halte das gerade, also wenn du mal in diesem Block wart, gerade aus, es gibt dann so einen Aufgang hoch quasi, einen Ausgang raus, erhalte ich das so aus, also ich weiß, Bielefelds Auswärtsblock ist furchtbar, aber wenn ich dann einen neu baue, dann verstehe ich nicht, wie ich ihn baue und wie sowas abgenommen werden kann. Auch in einer Situation, beispielsweise die Sicherheitsbeauftragte, bei der ich dann da war, die hat ihre Handschuhe noch nicht mal an, obwohl seit einer Viertelstunde 900 Fans vorgestanden. Das fand ich dann doch auch komisch. Na ja, also alles so Punkte, wo ich mich tatsächlich auch frage, also, Muenzert baut sich jetzt dieses neue Stadion, vielleicht ist deshalb auch das Problem. Also, für den Derby kam da, glaube ich, irgendwann auch nicht mehr so ganz das Stadion mit, ehrlich gesagt. Das ist gerade in der zweiten Halbzeit dann doch so ein bisschen eingeschlafen. Das kann natürlich dann auch– ich meine, klar, das ist finanziert und so, aber es ist natürlich trotzdem auch nicht schön, gerade mit einem neuen Stadion dann da in der dritten Liga mit anzutreten. Also, na, ja.
Sollen wir noch vielleicht zwei Worte zu Münster sagen, dass es vermutlich jetzt der besiegelte Abstieg war mit diesem Spiel? Es ist ein bisschen wie bei Bochum natürlich, ja, wenn man sich die Punkte anguckt, ist das natürlich theoretisch noch möglich. Aber auch hier wieder dasselbe Problem. Die Teams unten nehmen sich teilweise gegenseitig die Punkte weg. Und Münsters Restprogramm ist knüppelig. Also Hannover auswärts als Nächstes, dann zu Hause gegen Darmstadt und dann auswärts in Elbersberg. Die Reaktionen der Spieler haben es auch gezeigt nach dem Spiel. Da waren auch ein paar Tränen am Start etc. Ich befürchte, dass war diese Heimniederlage der entscheidende Punkt zum Abstieg. Und ja, ganz überraschend, ich glaube, wir waren uns da in der Rasenfunkgruppe sehr schnell einig, dass vielleicht Alois Schwarz als Neuverpflichtung nicht der absolute Schachzug ist, den man in dieser Situation bräuchte. Und ja, einen Sieg hat er noch nicht geholt, glaube ich, wenn man das richtig sieht, ein paar 0 zu 0s. Also, ehrlicherweise genau das, was man von Alois Schwarz erwarten darf. Sorry für den Diss an dieser Stelle, aber für mich kein Zweitligatrainer.
Ja, und ich finde, sie strahlen nach was anderes auch, auch in den Interviews nach dem Spiel, als die Vörter, die sich irgendwie in so eine fränkische Hypnose begeben haben, habe ich so das Gefühl. Also das ist ja wirklich eine, das geht aber auch von Heiko Vogel aus, wirklich ein stoisches Vorgehen dort in dieser Tabellenregion, die dann aber eben einfach so plötzlich aus der Kiste springen. Und ich grundsätzlich den Vörtern zutraue, was ich Münster aktuell nicht mehr zutraue, dass die noch mal eine überraschende, von niemandem antizipierte Serie hinlegen, weil irgendwie niemand so richtig weiß, warum Furt doll gewinnt und dann wieder doll verliert. Deswegen würde ich da tatsächlich sagen, weiß ich nicht genau, was passiert. Bei Münster habe ich den Vibe nicht, also auch nicht in den Interviews gehabt.
Wo du sie gerade reinbringst, Furt, natürlich auch nicht mit einem leichten Restprogramm. Sie spielen jetzt das Derby gegen den Klub. Das wird der Klub, der im Grunde gerettet ist, noch mehr als Bochum. Der Klub wird sehr ernst nehmen, weil es einfach das Derby ist. Dann spielen sie auswärts bei Hertha. Ja, Hertha ist keine Heim-Macht in dieser Saison, aber auch da wird man im letzten Heim-Spiel wahrscheinlich sehr motiviert sein, auch noch mal alles zu einem vernünftigen Ende zu bringen. Und dann kommt eben das Finale wahrscheinlich gegen Fortuna des Love.
Ja, aber sie hatten halt diese weirden Siege gegen Hannover und Elbersberg. Und seitdem traue ich Fjord einfach nicht mehr über Nick. Muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen. Also, was weiß ich, was da passiert. Das und irgendwie finde ich das misstrauenerweckend. Aber irgendwie auch ganz cool, so richtig schlau werde ich da irgendwie nicht draußen, muss ich sagen. So viel sei mir zugestanden an Ratlosigkeit.
Und dann kommen wir zu unserem letzten Verein, nämlich zur Eintracht aus Braunschweig. Da ist es nur ein Platz unter Aminia Bielefeld, nämlich Platz 14, 34 Punkte, 34 zu 50 Tore, 9 Siege, 7 Unentschieden und 15 Niederlagen stehen da zu Buche. Die Formtabelle, die zeigt Platz 14. Vor allem dank eines Sieges am Wochenende. Davor waren es 2 Unentschieden, 2 Niederlagen, nach 4 Spielen ohne Sieg. Auch hier Düsseldorf war der letzte Sieg davor. Jetzt ein Sieg zum richtigen Zeitpunkt. Es gab eben dieses 2 zu 0 gegen Kaiserslautern am Freitagabend. Vielleicht erst mal, Anna, du warst da, du hast die Weinschorle genossen, hast du gesagt. Du hast gesagt, wenn ich zitieren darf, also Abschließkampf braucht auch kein Fußballspielen. Möchtest du das kurz erklären?
Ja, also ganz kurz ausgeholt. Wir hatten jetzt gerade eine Phase, in der wir durchaus Fußball gespielt haben, es nicht nur versucht haben, sondern tatsächlich ordentlich was mit dem Ball zustande bekommen haben. Auf der einen Seite, auf der anderen Seite komplett ohne Ertrag. Also wir hatten zwar diesen Auftakt-Sieg, das meint, wir hatten einen Trainerwechsel. Mitte der Rückrunde, nachdem wir gegen Münster bedauerlicherweise verloren haben zu Hause in einem wirklich absolut erbärmlichen Zweitligaspiel, hat der vormalige Trainer Heiner Backhaus noch die Partie gegen Paderborn bekommen, wo ein 1-1 überraschend erzielt werden konnte. Zu dem Zeitpunkt stand laut Benjamin Kessel aber schon fest, dass der Trainer gehen wird und nur noch die Formalitäten geregelt werden mussten, dass Lars Konnetka da jetzt schalten und walten darf. Und der möchte nicht nur kontern und nicht nur warten und nicht nur Fehler ausnutzen, sondern tatsächlich aktiv ein Spiel gestalten, kontrollieren. Er möchte die aktive Mannschaft sein und aktiver grundsätzlich auch als der Gegner. Und das sah wirklich gut aus. Nach diesem 1 zu 0 gegen Fortuna Düsseldorf im Heimspiel folgte dann das Derby, in dem wir absolut nicht die schlechtere Mannschaft waren, trotzdem eben 1 zu 0 verlieren. Und dann folgte eine Durststrecke. Die Heimspieler haben wir immerhin nicht verloren, konnten sie aber auch nicht gewinnen. Auswärts sah es schlechter aus und ich war tatsächlich schon etwas beunruhigt, weil auf der einen Seite zeigte die Mannschaft ein spielerisch komplett anderes Gesicht und auch die Spieler sagten in Interviews, dass es sie freut, dass sie endlich einen Plan an die Hand bekommen. Und ich finde das immer so interessant, weil ja im Fußball dafür ist das Geschäft ja viel zu eng, weil niemand explizit schlecht übereinander spricht, aber dann nicht mal im Subtext, sondern irgendwo zwischen gesagtem Unsubtext, dann doch sehr deutlich zum Vorschein kommt, was für Defizite vorher offenbar da gewesen sein müssen. Und die Frage natürlich sich aber stellt, ist das zeitlich vielleicht einfach zu ambitioniert? Hat die Mannschaft zu wenig Möglichkeiten, in diese komplette Veränderung an Spielphilosophie reinzufinden? Beziehungsweise ist sie gut genug, dafür den Abstiegskampf spielerisch für sich zu entscheiden? Ich bin wirklich froh, dass Lars Konnetka sich nicht zu stolz war, um von dieser ursprünglichen Spielidee abzuweichen. Und in Kaiserslautern ein absolut freches Fußballspiel präsentiert hat, indem er ausgenutzt hat, dass Kaiserslautern trotz der nicht besonders aufregenden Rebellenregionen, in der der Verein gerade steht, zu Hause arg unter Druck stand, nachdem er in der Woche zuvor in Kiel abgefertigt worden ist und dann unter der Woche gesagt worden ist, man würde ein anderes Gesicht zeigen, man will sich bei den Fans revanchieren und so weiter und so fort. Und du halt arg gemerkt hast, nach dem Führungstreifer in der 14. oder 15. Minute, nach einem Torwartfehler des 18-jährigen 2. Liga-Debütanten, den wir für uns nutzen konnten, dass halt die Stimmung nach und nach kippt. Und ich würde sagen, dass wir weniger gegen Kaiserslautern gewonnen haben, als dass sie gegen sich selbst verloren haben. Und das war riskant, das hätte nicht aufgehen müssen. Ich bin sehr überrascht, dass gerade dieser Trainer sich für einen Spielansatz entschieden hat, der mündet in weniger als 30 Prozent Ballbesitz, 0,7 Expected Goals und zwei Toren. Aber vielleicht muss man auch einfach einsehen zu diesem Zeitpunkt in der Saison, wenn du eine Mannschaft dort übernimmst, wo sie steht, dass du nicht alles von ihr verlangen kannst. Spiel gestalten, Spiel dominieren, effektiv sein und hinten stabil stehen. Dass das einfach ein zu viel ist für ein Team, das auch keinen Footgoy hat und keinen Hoffmann, der vorne einfach steht und die Dinger macht und einen mehr als die Jungs hinten reinlassen. Und das steckt hinter dieser Aussage, also 27 Prozent Ballbesitz und ein schlitzohriges, also wir haben, das ist so witzig, wir haben einfach zwei Spiele mit mehr als einem Torunterschied gewonnen und das war das Hinspiel gegen Casas Lauten, 2 zu 0 und das Rückspiel auch 2 zu 0. Na ja, solche Geschichten schreibt nur der Fußball.
Thorsten, was hast du für positive Worte zur Eintracht-Braunschei zu verlegen oder warum hebst du hier deine Hand?
Ich habe zwei Punkte, die ich zu dieser Partie loswerden möchte. Das eine habe ich im Vorgespräch geteasert. Ihr wisst ja, dass der Kicker immer in seinen Aufstellungen am Ende ein kurzes Fazit zu einer Partie schreibt und eine Spielnote gibt. Und ich wollte Anna damit kurz konfrontieren und mal sehen, wie sie darauf reagiert. Also Kickerspielnote 6. Braunschweig spielte wie ein Absteiger und siegte dennoch verdient. Über die Leistung der Gastgeber ist damit alles gesagt. FCK-Sportdirektor Klos fasste es zusammen. Am Fernseher hätte man dieses Spiel wohl einfach ausgeschaltet. Fand ich schon krass als Zusammenfassung. Kannst du gleich was zu sagen, ob es vielleicht sogar stimmt. Und ich möchte ein bisschen outcallen, dass man in einem Abstiegskampf, in dem es für viele Mannschaften um sehr viel geht, dass man in einer Partie gegen einen Gegner, der mittendrin in diesem Abstiegskampf ist, seinen 18-jährigen Nachwuchstorhüter ein Zweitligaspiel schenkt und er dieses dann auch entsprechend beeinflusst. Innis Kamga ist ein großes Talent des deutscher U19-Nationalkeeper. Es steht außer Zweifel, dass das ein guter Junge ist. Darum geht es mir hier auch nicht. Sondern um dieses Geschmäckle, dass man den sportlichen Wettbewerb damit beeinflusst. Ich finde, das macht man einfach nicht. Das macht man am letzten Spieltag, wenn man gegen wen spielt, für den es auch um nichts geht. Das neue Trikot hat man von der neuen Saison schon an. Dann macht man das, aber nicht mitten im Abstiegskampf. Das wollte ich ein bisschen outcoilen, weil ich finde, das setzt auch bei einer Mannschaft das Signal. Und die lautere Leistung zeigt das ja. Ja, es ist jetzt irgendwie alles egal und vorbei. Jetzt machen wir auch mal sowas. Und so haben sie dann auch im Endeffekt gespielt. Ihr habt davon profitiert und dir wird das egal sein. Aber mich ärgert das logischerweise als Düsseldorfer total, wenn ich sehe, das wird so random einfach gemacht und entscheidet das Spiel dann. Das wollte ich kurz outcoilen. Darum ist lieber Knecht ein bisschen selber schuld, wenn er da jetzt richtig Unruhe in der Bude hat.
Ja, das kann ich grundsätzlich verstehen, hatte aber nicht den Eindruck, dass wir gegen eine Mannschaft gespielt haben, der es egal war, wie sie sich präsentiert. Ich habe, glaube ich, selten eine so heftige Publikumsreaktion mitbekommen. Die Leute sind gegangen und haben in der Halbzeit schon gepfiffen. Und nach Spielende war da– also all das, was vorher laut und positiv war, war immer noch laut, aber überhaupt nicht positiv. Ich frage mich, aus welchen konkreten Aspekten Kaisers Lauten einen Anspruch artikuliert, dem man so wenig gerecht geworden ist, dass es eine so krasse Unzufriedenheit rechtfertigt. Das kann ich nicht bewerten. Ich war wirklich überrascht, weil ja, sie haben gegen Kiel verloren, aber davor haben sie ja trotz einer schwachen Auswärtsbilanz in Berlin gegen Hertha gewonnen. Also grundsätzlich ist alles so ganz in Ordnung, aber diese Unzufriedenheit darüber, dass man sich so früh aus dem Abstiegskampf verabschiedet hat, scheint halt punktuell um uns herum gegen Trainer-Diskussionen, also die volle Palette. Und meine Interpretation, auch die Stimmen der Spieler, unserer Spieler nach dem Spiel, war, dass du das antizipieren konntest und das gesagt worden ist, man wäre selbst ungern heute das Heimteam gewesen, weil es so unangenehm gewesen ist.
Die Region ist wütend.
Ja, offenbar. Also mich hat das nicht gestört.
Aber Anna, dann lass uns doch nach dem kleinen Ausflug Richtung Kaiserslautern, weil, also ja, Thorsten hat eben vorgelesen, spielte wie ein Absteiger. Du hast jetzt schon so ein bisschen die Vergangenheit, seitdem Lars Konnetka eben da ist. Was gibt dir denn Hoffnung auf ein weiteres Jahr 2. Liga? Weil ich glaube, man muss auch sagen, also keiner ist so gut auf Abstiegskampf vorbereitet wie du per se. Das ist überhaupt nicht despektierlich gemeint. Ich hoffe, du weißt, was ich damit meine. Denn man muss ja sagen, Eintracht Braunschweig findet sich mal wieder an der gleichen Stelle wie in den vergangenen Jahren eigentlich auch. Was gibt dir denn Hoffnung, was dieses Mal, also es hat ja auch in den letzten Jahren obviously immer gereicht, aber was gibt dir denn Hoffnung, dass es auch in diesem Jahr klappt?
Dass ich genau diesem Detail widersprechen wollen würde. Ich würde aus der Tatsache, dass wir verdient gewonnen haben, und das ist wirklich witzig, weil du das, also sowas erst nach dem Spiel sagen kannst, wenn du halt zu dem Schluss kommst, ja, du machst aus sehr wenig zwei Tore, aber du lässt auch unglaublich wenig zu. Es ist nicht so, das war, Kaiserslautern hat nicht gespielt wie Hertha. Das war nicht so, dass man gesagt hat, aiaiai, da hätte aber irgendwie der Videobeweis und hier der Posten und da die Latte. Sondern der Torhüter entschärft einen Kopfball und dann gibt es noch ein, zwei Situationen, die ja irgendwie ein bisschen heißer sind, aber ansonsten hast du das einfach gut im Griff, was halt in einem schrecklichen Spiel mündet. Und dieses im Griff haben in der Defensive hatte nicht zum Resultat einen guten Spielaufbau oder zweite Bälle waren auch. Das hat alles nicht gut funktioniert auf der einen Seite. Auf der anderen Seite, finde ich, verliert ein Absteiger dieses Spiel. Und mir gibt wirklich Hoffnung, dass ich den Eindruck habe, dass der Trainer, dessen erste Profi-Station das ist, er ist das erste Mal Chef-Trainer, er ist Co-Trainer von Ralph Rangnick in der österreichischen Nationalmannschaft. Das bleibt er auch über die Weltmeisterschaft hinweg tatsächlich. Und es ist völlig unklar, wie würde er sich schlagen, wie passt so seine Spielidee, seine Idee von Fußball nicht nur zu Eintracht Braunschweig, sondern auch zu Eintracht Braunschweig in dieser Situation. Und die Tatsache, dass er sich innerhalb von wenigen Spielen viel flexibler zeigt und viel weniger beharrt auf das, was er findet, wie Fußball gespielt werden muss, als der Trainer, den wir davor hatten. In Kombination damit, dass die Mannschaft wieder Fußball spielen möchte bis kann, glaube ich daran– ich hatte es gestern in der Aufnahme von unserem Gegenrade-Podcast gesagt –,Dass wir Kiel schlagen können und auch Dresden zu Hause. Das ist relativ weit aus dem Fenster gelehnt, das ist mir völlig klar. Aber auch da könnt ihr euch vielleicht ins Verhältnis setzen. Es gibt in solchen Saisons nicht so viele Spieltage, nach denen man ein bisschen mal laut sein kann. Oder an denen man gute Laune haben kann. Und deswegen sage ich das jetzt hier. So, 6 Punkte in den nächsten zwei Spielen.
Du weißt mit wem du hier sprichst.
Das wären ja tatsächlich auch meine Fragen gewesen. Du hast Kiel, Dresden und dann kommt Schalke. Wir gehen jetzt einfach mal zu einem Zeitpunkt aus. Schalke ist zu dem Zeitpunkt aufgestiegen. Schalke ist die Meisterschaft auch schon klar. Vielleicht kann man ja auch ein bisschen davon profitieren, dass dann eine Woche Malle oder so dazwischen war. Obwohl ich nicht glaube, dass eine… Also vielleicht zweimal bei Mäckis, aber in einer Mannschaft unter Miro Muslice. Also ich glaube, der will dann schon auch bis zum letzten Spiel das durchziehen. Aber ich finde das halt wirklich interessant, weil– also Anna, wir kennen uns jetzt auch schon ein bisschen und ich wage mich auch zu erinnern, wir haben schon so die eine oder andere Folge zum Saison-Endspurt aufgenommen und gefühlt habe ich dich aber auch einfach noch nie so positiv gehört. Also, dass du halt nicht nur dieses Jahr, wir müssen mal schauen, was der Rest macht und ob unsere Leistung reicht oder so, sondern auch diese, ja selber, diese Offensive, das ist dann ja auch was, was sich Lars Konnetka sehr schnell erarbeitet hat. Und das ist dann natürlich, also und dass du ja auch irgendwie das Gefühl hast, so wie ich das raushöre, man hat eben das Gefühl, dass was dann im Sommer passiert, da vielleicht werden da endlich mal die richtigen Weichen auch bestellt, weil man muss ja, also es ist dann ja trotzdem so ein bisschen Groundhog Day, weil du will, also trotzdem muss es dann jetzt ja mal klappen. Also ab irgendeinem Zeitpunkt muss Eintracht Braunschweig die Wege finden, weil also natürlich bist du die ganze Zeit 2. Liga und alleine deshalb, also das ist für Fernsehgelder schon mal gut, aber also auch da wäre ja schon mal ganz cool, dann vielleicht mal ein bisschen höher zu sein, weil Potenzial am Standort Eintracht Braunschweig ist ja weiterhin da, ne? Also, dass man und trotzdem– correct me if I'm wrong– aber es ist ja schon so, dass auch irgendwann aus dem Verein und aus den Fans heraus auch irgendwann mal dann diese Anforderungen in den Verein gestellt wird, so ey, jetzt mach doch aber auch mal was damit.
Ja, definitiv. Und ich glaube, was heilsam wäre, wäre wenigstens ab und zu so eine Saison wie Magdeburg in dem letzten Jahr, dass man das Gefühl hat, es passiert was. Und natürlich kann das danach wieder anders rumlaufen. Aber dass es überhaupt einen Trend gibt und dass der im besten Fall auch noch positiv ist. Und den kannst du aber bei uns leider nicht erkennen. Was auch daran liegt, ist, ja, das ist einfach. Also in dieser Saison haben wir im Unterschied zu der letzten Saison keinen Goalgetter. Rayon Philippe hat in der vergangenen Saison wesentlich dazu beigetragen, dass wir die Klasse halten konnten über den Umweg Relegation. Wo dort dann Christian Conté aufgeblüht ist, der dann ja auch maßgeblich dazu beigetragen hat, dass die Hinrunde ganz gut funktioniert hat, den du dann aber gehen lassen musstest. Nach Heidenheim, da hatte er noch ein halbes Jahr Vertrag und hat eineinhalb Millionen eingespült. Das ist natürlich ein gigantischer Posten. Aber Conté ist, obwohl er seit Dezember nicht mehr für André Braunschweig spielt, immer noch einer unserer besten Vorschützen und einer unserer besten Vorlagengeber. Und da siehst du halt, dass das, was verändert worden ist, also der Trainer, der jetzt in vielen Belangen eine ganz andere Herangehensweise hat, die ganz andere Ergebnisse nach sich zieht, aber diese Veränderung der Spielphilosophie nicht kompensieren kann, dass der Kader unterdurchschnittlich gut ist.
Also er ist besser als letzte Saison. Und du siehst auch Formkurven nach oben. Aber der Kader kann halt nicht kompensieren, dass er das Tor nicht trifft. Das ist halt irgendwie schwierig dann langfristig. Also, ja, gut, jetzt kommen wir wirklich hier in den großen Phrasenbereich, den ich nicht dreschen möchte. Aber auch das, du hast gefragt, was gibt mir Hoffnung. Faride Alidu hat getroffen, den wir lustigerweise aus Kaiserslautern für ein halbes Jahr geliehen haben. Und im Vorfeld wurde gesagt, ah, der steht im Kader. Naja, wir wissen alle, was passiert. Also nicht von Braunschweiger Seite, sondern von Lauterer Seite. Miatovic hat bei seinem nationalen Mannschaftseinsatz getroffen und im Spiel gegen Nürnberg, meine ich. Und ja, Demicci hat wieder getroffen gegen Kaiserslautern. Das heißt, die Stürmer sind grundsätzlich so ein... Also ich traue mich noch nicht, vom geplatzen Knoten zu sprechen. Aber vielleicht der Schnürsenkel, an dem so ein bisschen... Es ist kein Doppelknoten mehr in der Schleife. Da könnte man noch anknüpfen.
Es wird zu so einem Angler, so einem Seglerknoten, den man ja meistens sehr super kompliziert aufzubauen ist und den man ja eigentlich schnell wieder auflösen kann. Ja, ich finde, also wie gesagt, ich finde es wirklich sehr interessant, weil ich nämlich zustimmen würde, dass ich von... Also wenn man so ein Ranking erstellen müsste, von da unten drin, sehe ich eben Braunschweig schon in einer besseren Situation. Einfach weil... Also es kann ja am Ende dann trotzdem auch psychologisch ein wichtiger Faktor sein, zu wissen, okay, wir haben es halt in den vergangenen Jahren irgendwie immer geschafft. Auch wenn natürlich dann nicht gleicher Trainer, nicht immer die gleiche Mannschaft, aber das kann natürlich vielleicht im Endspurt auch von Fanseite einfach nochmal den Push geben. Und da bin ich tatsächlich sehr, sehr gespannt. Also wir haben eben gesagt, Kiel, Dresden, Schalke. Da sehe ich gerade in den ersten beiden Spielen. Und ich meine, man muss trotzdem bei allem sagen, also bis auf das Spiel gegen Münster hat Schalke ja auch durchaus auch noch Rückgründe, zum Teil seine Probleme mit Abschiebskandidaten gehabt, weil es einfach eine andere…
Hört, hört.
Ja, also ist natürlich auch für Frau Dona Lissendorf am Wochenende interessant. Also vielleicht schafft man es da auch, wie gesagt, dann trotzdem irgendwie Schalke 04 in den Unentschieden und so abzuringen. Und das könnte ja ein wichtiger Punkt, weil ich sage es hier auch gerne nochmal. Thematik, Torverhältnis, das spricht in der Gesamtkonstellation, gerade wenn du jetzt auf Magdeburg guckst, auf Bielefeld guckst, auf Dresden guckst, auch eventuell noch auf Kiel, jetzt nicht unbedingt für Braunschweig bei minus 16. Aber sie haben ja auf jeden Fall schonmal das bessere Torverhältnis gegenüber, für Münster und von Dona Lissendorf. Und das kann natürlich, gerade dass du eben noch zwei Partien hast, wo du jetzt nicht davon ausgehen kannst, dass du im Zweifel brutal abgeschossen wirst, sondern eben das auch irgendwann noch so ein psychologischer Faktor sein kann. Das wird dann natürlich schon eine ganz interessante Nummer eben raus. Ich bin wirklich, also ich glaube, wir drei sind uns einig. Abschießkampf ist wirklich, wirklich anstrengend. Und wir freuen uns wirklich ganz doll, wenn das vorbei ist. Und man muss ja auch einfach sagen, es macht es zum Teil doppelt schwer, weil ich liebe diese Oldstars-Gruppe. Aber man will ja zum einen, also ich wünsche keinem von euch, dass euer Verein absteigt. Einfach, weil ich ganz egoistisch gerne möchte, dass ihr in dieser Oldstars-Runde drin bleibt. Ich aber auch verstehen kann, wenn ihr sagt, hier, Alter, wenn wir nächstes Jahr 3. Liga gucken müssen, ziehe mir doch nicht noch diesen 2. Liga-Quatsch da rein. Und deshalb macht es das aus emotionaler Sicht auch mit Vereinen, wo man vielleicht jetzt im ersten Moment nicht denken würde, da hält man jetzt irgendwie emotional mit. Macht es das irgendwie noch mal doppelt anstrengend, weil ich sage das jetzt gerne noch mal, also in der unteren Tabellenhälfte Bielefeld, Braunschweig, Düsseldorf, Magdeburg führt. Ja, das ist äußerteam represented. Das macht es irgendwie nicht besser, ehrlich gesagt. Und wir haben alle unsere Sticheleien in der Gruppe, aber ich finde das trotzdem irgendwie, es ist irgendwie trotzdem auf beiden, ich glaube auch für die Ausstiegsmenschen, es ist irgendwie kollektiv trotzdem schön, gemeinsam zu leiden, gemeinsam sich auch zu gratulieren. Und ich sage das auch gerne noch mal, es freut mich sehr, dass wir uns zwischendurch auch immer wieder treffen in den Stadien. Es gibt immer fleißigen Bilderaustausch. Und das finde ich tatsächlich sehr schön und ich finde es sehr schade, wenn wir in der nächsten Saison deshalb Mitglieder dieser Gruppe verlieren. Das finde ich einfach nicht schön. Also, weiß ich nicht.
Jahrestreffen bei Hoffenheim 2.
Um Gottes Willen.
Och, och, also muss jetzt nicht. Außen muss jetzt nicht.
Das war vielleicht auch nicht ganz ernst gemeint.
Gut.
Gibt es sonst noch, Anna, etwas, was du zu Eintracht Braunschweig loswerden möchtest?
Ich glaube nicht tatsächlich. Was mir gerade noch eingefallen ist, ist natürlich Lino Tempelmann, der alte Schalker, der lange verletzt war und jetzt immer mehr fit ist und immer mehr Spielzeit schafft. Und der das durchaus auch noch mal verändert. Und ich finde, dadurch, dass im Winter weggegangen ist, Sven Köhler, der Kapitän Richtung Graz Hoppers Zürich, abgesehen von fußballerischer Qualität, du einfach gemerkt hast, diese Hierarchie, Disbalance, die einfach nicht eingepegelt ist, weil es niemanden gibt, der in dieser schwierigen Situation etwas tragen kann. Und dass es total wichtig ist, dass ein Faktor, der aushalten kann und dagegen hält und Verantwortung übernimmt und den Ball haben möchte, Christian Streich in diesem einen legendären Interview so schön gesagt hat. Also, ja, ich hoffe, ich täusche mich nicht. Ich finde, es gibt mehr Dinge, die uns Braunschweigern gerade Mut machen, als dass sie uns verzagen lassen sollten. Und bin einfach unglaublich gespannt, wie diese Liga ausgeht, weil ich kann auch nicht mehr. Ich weiß nicht, wie es euch geht, aber ich kann auch nicht mehr. Dieser– also, wir haben Freitag gespielt, dann Samstag, okay. Aber sogar die Spiele, an denen man nicht beteiligt, das sind ja anstrengend. Das muss einfach jetzt aufhören. Ich habe auch keine Lust mehr.
Es ist halt ein großer Unterschied, finde ich, ob man als neutraler Zuschauer das einfach als Entertainment verfolgt oder wie wir jetzt wirklich sehr nah dran an den Vereinen sind. Und nah dran bedeutet dann manchmal auch persönlich, dass man Menschen kennt, Menschen kennt, um deren Jobs es geht, etc. Und das kriegt halt dann nochmal eine neue Ebene, ne? Das ist dann nicht mehr nur die Unterhaltungsebene, weil wir gucken alle Fußball zur Unterhaltung. Aber man kennt dann halt auch Menschen, die persönlich davon betroffen sind und ich sag mal, Spieler, Trainer, die fallen alle weich, aber vielleicht nicht normale Angestellte und so. Und das berührt mich dann tatsächlich am meisten. Und ich würde das gerne manchmal ausblenden, auch an den Nicht-Spieltagen. Aber im Moment fällt mir das persönlich super schwierig.
Ja, das ist vielleicht nicht mehr ein guter Schlusspunkt für diese Sendung. Also ich könnte mit euch immer noch gerne, aber trotzdem kommen wir mal zum Ende. Per se kann man glaube ich einfach echt sagen, ich stelle tatsächlich auch immer wieder fest, klar ist es auch nicht immer geil, irgendwie, weiß ich nicht, 400 Kilometer für eine 4.1-Klatsche zu fahren, aber ich stelle trotzdem immer wieder fest, was für ein Unterschied es macht, irgendwie live im Stadion zu sein und dann hat man trotzdem den Austausch mit Freundinnen, mit Bekannten oder du sitzt irgendwie nur vorm Fernseher und guckst dir das an. Da habe ich, wenn ich das vergleiche mit vor 3 oder 4 Jahren oder gerade so zu Corona-Zeiten, da ist schon ein wahnsinnig großer Unterschied und ich habe auch das Gefühl, es ist gleichzeitig so eine gewisse Gleichgültigkeit dann zum Teil drin, weil du denkst, ok, ich kann jetzt sowieso gerade nichts machen, also ich stehe jetzt hier und ich gebe alles irgendwie für den Verein zum Supporten, aber ich gucke halt auch nicht in die Leute, also in die Köpfe rein und trotzdem nimmt es einen ja auch irgendwie mit und wie gesagt, liebe Münsterfans, bitte nicht böse sehen, natürlich auch qua Revalität und natürlich auch qua Tabellensituation. Wenig da jetzt ich traurig rum, aber trotzdem kann ich das schon verstehen, wenn das dann, also Abschiebenskampf ist einfach scheiße und das tut einfach weh und von einem, wenn man dann wahrscheinlich irgendwelche Bekannten hat, die sagen, also es ist ja nur Fußball und das ist immer ein bisschen schwierig, weil es ist eben nicht nur Fußball. Und dann möchte ich aber auch diese Folge zum Ende bringen. Ich freue mich sehr, sehr, dass ihr beide Zeit gefunden habt, diese Liga mit mir zu besprechen, den Spieltag, die Vereine. Lieben Dank als erstes an Anna Lautenbach, die hier back-to-back dabei war. Danke, Anna.
Danke für die Einladung, war super. Und ich hoffe so doll, dass ich nächste Saison wieder mitmachen kann, einfach weil die Eintracht wieder mit dabei ist. Niemand weiß warum, aber es wäre so schön.
Und natürlich auch lieben Dank an Thorsten Wiese. Danke, Thorsten. Ich hoffe, dass du auch in– und dann hoffen wir mal, dass auch dein Streak im Rasenfunk erfolgreich weitergeht.
Ja, genau. Vielen Dank auch hier für die Einladung. Und ja, vielleicht gibt es ja Richtung Saisonende nochmal die Chance, diesen Streak zu überprüfen.
Schauen wir mal. Und sonst bedanke ich mich ganz recht herzlich fürs Zuhören. In zwei Wochen hört ihr mich dann mit Marc. Da geben wir euch dann ein Special. Was wird wichtig für den Endspurt bis dahin. Macht's gut, bleibt gesund und bis zum nächsten Mal.
Tschüss.
Der Rasenfunk lebt von euren Beiträgen. Vielen Dank.